jahrelang geisterte die möglichkeit eher
wie eine verschwörungstheorie durchs
netz denn niemand konnte die funktion
beweisen diese antrieb war
wissenschaftlich nicht nachweisbar und
kein wissenschaftler wollte sich durch
eine vielleicht eher spekulative
veröffentlichung den ruf ruinieren zu
dem widersprach die funktion den dritten
newtonschen gesetz aktion gleich
reaktion
doch das sensationelle dieser antrieb
scheint trotz allem zu funktioniert
wieso weshalb warum jetzt endlich zum
zweiten weg zum herzen gekommen
wir hatten ja schon ein paar mal
wissenschaftlich bestätigt ist nur etwa
wenn das ergebnis eines experiments oder
eine theorie überprüft worden ist genau
das ist mit dem em drive geschehen
dieser höchst seltsame antrieb scheint
tatsächlich zu funktionieren und dabei
ist er nicht mal ein richtiger
raketenantrieb denn damit verbindet man
eine menge schob eine riesige menge
schulpreise gase und viel lärm
das alles gibt es hier nicht was hat es
aber damit auf sich erfunden hat diesen
antrieb der dritte rodgersia ein
ehemaliger projektleiter des
europäischen raumfahrtkonzerns astrium
der inzwischen zu airbus gehört also
jemand der absolut ahnung von der
materie hat
doch das was er da konstruiert hat hat
nicht nur kaum jemand verstanden wie man
konnte es auch nachprüfen und so gab es
deutlich mehr skeptiker die diesen
antrieb schicht herum buch lesen so
etwas konnte nicht funktionieren ein
antrieb der das dritte jüdische gesetz
also dass ihr aktueller klub eng
verletzt ja das konnte ich geben doch
die nasa wollte der sache auf den grund
gehen wie hat ein labor das darauf
spezialisiert ist antrieben für
raumschiffe zu testen das eagle works
rapper ti im linden be johnson space
center
dort wurde wer auf scheuert prinzip
gebaute canet antrieb auf herz und
nieren geprüft
der konstrukteur video vetter benannte
ihn wahrscheinlich sagen einem ausbruch
von chefingenieur scotty vom raumschiff
enterprise keinen chains of physics in
seinen extrem schottischen akzent you
can't change the loss of music man kann
die gesetze der physik nicht ändern aber
vielleicht doch oder anders es scheint
gesetze der physik zu geben auf der
diese andere beruht die das drittel
newtons gesetz ich würde mal sagen
umgehen das von zieht dabei ist echt
abgefahren und alles andere als einfach
in einem behälter werden mit strom
mikrowellen erfolgt wie bleiben in den
behälter und erzeugen nach außen hin
einen strahlungsdruck dieser schrank der
ist schon lange bekannt und wird durch
elektromagnetische wellen also licht
oder eben mikrowellen verursacht
elektromagnetische wellen das ist die
theorie üben also druck aus und dieser
druck wattiefe einen antrieb verwendet
was er 72 wurde das auch kann
konkret beobachtet der physiker aber es
ging richtete laserlicht auf kleine
plastikkügelchen und konnte eine
bewegungs änderung beobachten es geht
also auch so stark dass er wirklich
etwas bewegen kann und das macht er
scheinbar auch in diesem fall die nasa
wissenschaftler konnten schub messen
allerdings in homöopathischen also
minimale dosen 30 bis 130 minuten also
00 00 03 bis 0 0 0 0 1 3 newton das ist
praktisch gar nichts aber auch nicht
null und das besondere
jetzt wurde diese studie in peer review
verfahren vom wissenschafts kolleginnen
und kollegen gegengecheckt und er
bestätigt dass kein methodischer fehler
vorliegt sie ist damit in der welt das
heißt zwar noch nicht dass der antrieb
wirklich zu einer content funktioniert
aber es spricht inzwischen werde vieles
dafür was will man aber mit einem
antrieb machen der fast keinen schub
erfolg die antwort ist ganz einfach umso
länger ein solcher antrieb fast keinen
schub erfolg desto schneller für das
raumschiff trotzdem und schneller und
schneller und es würde kein treibstoff
benötigt werde lediglich solarstrom oder
in dem fall dann später sternen
strompreisen nötig ja um durch das
weltall zu reisen wahnsinn wenn du mir
zu dem thema geht dann mache ich
natürlich ein video dazu wenn jetzt
nichts verpassen wollt mir ein abo aufs
auge und nicht den ausweg woche
vergessen
hier sind alle videos zum thema
raumfahrt verlinkt draufklicken und
staunt ja was bleibt mir jetzt noch zu
sagen ja
bis gleich